die weihnachtszeit das ist ja auch immer
so ein bisschen die schüler machten zeit
die versuchungen die liegen überall sie
sehen jetzt hier immer ein partner im
studio personaltrainer am markt
zinkernagel wir sprechen gleich über
diese ganz tollen sachen ja ich muss
sagen ich gehör selbst so den schlanken
menschen aber weihnachten das schaffe
ich dann auch immer vier kilo mehr ich
schaffe es einfach nicht da dran weg zu
greifen wie werde ich diese pfunde los
was kostet mich so vanillekipferl zum
beispiel wie lange muss ich da joggen
also ein ist man ja selten ist sagen wir
mal wenn du ja so 34 ist nochmals 100
gramm
das hat schon so an die 500 kilokalorien
das heißt du bist schon na ja also 100
gramm ne ok 100 gramm sind vielleicht 45
stück ungefähr nichts neues nichts
deswegen empfehle ich dir im vorfeld
schon mal oder eben der zuschauer lange
kauen lässt sich länger genießen und
dann hat man vielleicht auch nicht ganz
so viel lust auf noch 67 andere stück
aber was man machen müsste man mal bei
100 gramm 45 stück wäre ja wer schon 40
minuten joggen aber ist doch schön ist
doch schön herum geben
also ich bin ja ich bin persönlich
ehrlich gesagt wirklich nicht so der
große sport fan vielleicht geht es ja
einigen zuschauern auch so aber es geht
nur mit sport wirklich weg ist das so
naja also mit bewegung sondern mal so
mit bewegungen
ich würde auch empfehlen im vorfeld
bevor ich was es wirklich ganz ganz
präsent und mit ganz viel genuss
wirklich zu machen
es gibt nämlich dem körper auch das
gefühl okay wir tun es nicht weil wer
süchtig danach sind sondern weil wir
wirklich lust drauf war und dann kann
man den eigenen körperzellen auch so
einen so ein jahr also ein gefühl geben
hey verbrennen mal schneller verbrennen
mal schneller es geht wirklich mit
ganzen schöner tipp auch möglich sein ja
wirklich und ansonsten man kann ja auch
einfach das mit hausarbeit verbinden
also war also nur zum beispiel wenn man
die ganze wohnung saugt und man sagt
jetzt sagen wir mal was kommt darauf an
wie groß die wohnung ist 40 minuten
saugen ja im
in der bewegung sind schon sind schon
100 kalorien weg das sehe ich jetzt
schon die ganzen männer die zu hause
sagen wer heute sagt kalorien decken
kann man ja auch kombinieren und dann
mache ich noch ein paar park rangers ein
paar liegestütze oder ein paar
kniebeugen und saugt ein bisschen und
schon habe ich aber ich eben einiges weg
nicht einfach mit spaß ja und mag was
sind so die größten kalorie fallen
kalorien fallen wir haben ja hier schon
einiges aufgetischt was ist denn hier
jetzt also erst hier eigentlich ist ja
süß aber erst der meister würde ich
sagen
der meister der kalorien jetzt gedacht
die mandeln tatsächlich weil die so
voller hat zucker ja die haben es auch
in sich aber der hat mehr die mandeln
haben eben auch den großen vorteil dass
sie deutlich mehr proteine haben also
lieber nicht was ja wieder gut ist für
unser muskulatur und für vieles mehr
und er hat halt wahnsinnig viel fett
muss man es eben wirklich reine
schokolade mit relativ viel fett 30 30
prozent fett ungefähr
und ja der hat schon der hat schon seine
550 kalorien er her der kleiner und 550
kalorien heißt dann gleich mal nicht
nicht 30 40 minuten sondern dann der
otto normalverbraucher darf dann gleich
mal eine stunde joggen gehen oder
anderthalb stunden rad voran
wie schafft man jetzt also dann wie
gesagt ich fahre auch jedes jahr jedes
jahr ein kilo sowie vier plus ja krieg
rück ich locker hin jetzt so weit es
geht es dann über den ganzen dezember
und weihnachten dann volle kanne
ja
wie schaffe ich das dieses jahr
vielleicht mein gewicht zu halten was
ist der ultimative tipp genuss ok genuss
genau es wirklich mit ganz viel genuss
und präsenz zu machen ich würde
empfehlen im vorfeld schon so ein
kleines bisschen sport zu machen wenn
ich weiß da kommt jetzt so ein tag oder
sonnabend auf mich zu wo ich so richtig
bock habt zu schlemmen
dann mache ich vorher schon mal so ein
kleines bisschen kleines fitnessprogramm
zu hause oder geben bisschen länger
spazieren ja auch zu privaten zum
beispiel glühwein auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt an die weihnachtsmarkt
kann ja nicht aber zu hause glaube ich
werden jetzt viele glühwein trinken
trotzdem kleinen spaziergang machen das
hat dieser tipp wie man hat gar nicht so
viel sagen wir mal so 200 kalorien
sondern sonne so ein becher er so 200
millilitern ist ja meistens um pot 20
minuten 25 minuten spazieren gehen ist
das auch wieder erledigt also ich würde
echt empfehlen im vorfeld sich ein
bisschen mehr zu bewegen vielleicht auch
öfter mal statt den fahrstuhl die
treppen zu benutzen ja einfach auch
alltags möglichkeiten zu nutzen
vielleicht einen kleinen weg spazieren
zu gehen zum lebensmittel anstatt alles
mit dem auto zu machen
tipp sie natürlich immer gelten aber
gerade jetzt und dann vielleicht im
vorfeld ein bisschen mehr machen dass
man im nachhinein nicht oder beim essen
nicht jetzt schon gleich ein schlechtes
gewissen gericht und gibt es aus seiner
profi sicht absolute no-gos die man sich
wirklich nicht reinstopfen soll der
jetzt die nächsten tage
alles geht ja ja ja klar also was ist
schon lucona ist jeder muss das ja auch
mit sich selber abmachen ausmachen und
sagen ist es mir das jetzt wert und wenn
ja dann bitte ich auch wirklich genießen
und nicht mit schlechtem gewissen das
macht überhaupt keinen sinn wirklich
genießen und je mehr man genießt es
meiner erfahrung desto weniger braucht
man auch den größten fehler den wir alle
machen ist ich fange an zu essen bin mit
meinen gedanken aber noch ganz woanders
und es schon das dritte stück und
beginne dann erst an zugenäht fange dann
erst an zu genießen ist stimmt weil ich
die ersten zwei völlig verpasst habe
weil ich vielleicht noch damit
beschäftigt war und mit mit dem mann
gesprochen habe und merkt dann herr
mensch ich es ja schon ne weile fange
ich aber mit gleich mit dem ersten stück
an richtig zu genießen dann habe ich
vielleicht gar nicht auf 23 unbedingt so
ein riesenbedarf also deswegen ich komme
immer wieder darauf zurück präsent sein
beim essen wirklich genießen und alles
andere kann dann mal kurzfristig auch
alles andere
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren